a killer is headed to prison for the
rest of his life thanks for staying with
us here at 6 30. I'm Denise Valdez I'm
Brian Loftus this is a story the eight
news now investigators and Vanessa
Murphy have been closely following she
has the very latest on what may be the
final chapter in this murder case
this started with a missing persons case
nearly three years ago and ended in a
tragic way it's heartbreaking that the
memories that I have of her were
Stripped Away because all I can remember
is the terrible pain we had to tolerate
Cheryl Lynn beardall's son Achilles
facing his mother's killer in court
Wednesday Phillip O'Reilly offered no
apology Mr O'Reilly do you want to say
anything no you're wrong this is moments
before he received a sentence of life
without the possibility of parole
beerdahl's family giving O'Reilly a
send-off as he heads to prison her uncle
admitting thoughts of Revenge her mother
sharing the pain of losing a child what
gives a screaming mother
get out
a prison back in 2020 O'Reilly claimed
beard all picked up and left him in the
kids then the search for the mother of
three became a missing person's case
O'Reilly was arrested he was charged
with murder child abuse and sex crimes
against children it was revealed beardle
suffered long-term abuse by O'Reilly who
beat her with a dog leash with the
children present only knowing that they
have only seen her beaten to an inch of
her life and then be told that she left
them there with their abuser this is
beardle's Sister who the children now
live with O'Reilly tried to hire a hit
man from jail to kill her along with her
husband and two of the children who are
not biologically his once he knew he was
caught he agreed to a plea deal which
takes the death penalty off the table
part of me wasn't surprised as he had
put him through a roller coaster since
he entered Our Lives Jessica canoodle
also sharing a victim impact statement
from beardle's youngest Phillip killed
my Mommy Cheryl Lynn the five-year-old
girl is also O'Reilly's biological child
I
I want him to always stay in jail
forever so he can't hurt me anymore part
of O'Reilly's plea deal involved
revealing where he put beardall's body
her family revealed in court he said he
dismembered her remains and put them in
various locations her mother says she
doesn't even believe he told the truth
about that Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now